thank you
[Music]
so the DEA just had its biggest uh
seizure in New York City history of
fentanyl do you talk about the dick
enlargement agency right I could sign up
for that am I right brother
we're on another Weezer
I had whooping cough you [ __ ]
dude like literally mid weeds he starts
going from red to purple and that [ __ ]
[ __ ] starts to scare me every time I
had whooping cough I was 14. [ __ ] up
my lungs but you have to sell jokes with
whooping cough you have to get out of
your system
so
um and this kind of surprises me it
doesn't sound like a lot but uh the D.A
recovered 15
000 fentanyl pills wow but
um guess how they found them
I'm gonna say inside of tires
um what do you think
inside fruit
this is a new one by the way we haven't
heard this one oh we haven't heard this
Halloween decorations I thought they
were inside of hamsters how creative is
it
you know what it's not that creative so
like stuffed animals or something it's
close yeah we're overthinking in coffins
it is a toy of some sort oh RC cars
close they were able to uh drones
it's actually 15
000 of these rainbow colored fentanyl
pills were hidden amongst Legos in a
Lego box oh that's a genius same color
yeah they gotta sort it afterwards oh
holy [ __ ] that's a lot of work that's a
lot of work but it's still pretty smart
you think it goes into a scepter though
that can feel Legos and feel pills yeah
yeah you probably can semi you're gonna
question what does fentanyl by itself do
to you as a drug like what kind of
throws you against the wall over there
then I was like like you're dead man
yeah it just playing those [ __ ] crazy
I know people have been like oh Deanna
dying and people have been splicing
Fenton onto like regular things like
MDMA and all that did you have like like
little little amount of Fentanyl and
you're [ __ ] dead so why the [ __ ] like
you just take it to die that's right
that's what people love it because you
all it takes is like a drop and then
like whatever [ __ ] brick of cocaine
that you have it [ __ ] intensifies it
like crazy so now you can cut it up even
more cut it up with it yeah so you know
like we cut up conversationally with
stuff
they're cutting up but like with a
little bit of fentanyl thank you I was
looking for more details but thank you
for your okay answers everybody let's
[ __ ] back
dude take one little drop [ __ ]
[ __ ] backflip ten times back why do
you want to know so bad Anthony Lee
because it's been a constant thing that
comes up in conversation and I'm
somebody who has used drugs before and I
know that Joe's not here for the guy who
abuses drugs before
um but it's like when I actually think
about like we understand what MDMA does
we understand what we does cocaine
shrooms whatever but I don't actually
know the like the drug a recreational
understanding of what fentanyl actually
does and that's why I'm just asking if
anybody knows by description it's more
of a cutting thing because like if you
get baking soda you try to cuddle like I
don't know like baking soda I mean uh
cocaine it'll dilute it dilutes it use
fentanyl it's enhancement it's like holy
[ __ ] it's like FSG for you drug lord
what I don't understand is like they're
saying that one of these pills can kill
you yeah do you know who the [ __ ]
using Fentanyl and having a good time
and not dying no one that's what I was
saying like one of my cop buddies their
new protocol you know back then the
[ __ ] you pop open a trunk you see all
these duct tape packages it used to be
the
elastic and [ __ ] you know like now it's
if you see [ __ ] duct tape [ __ ] they
just immediately call guys that are like
hazmat suits okay because they can't
even do that because people have that
sucks literally stabbed it and just from
the puff of air [ __ ] three cops just
[ __ ] lay on the ground see that's
like you used to like get to be a cop
and like you go into a buffet that has a
police Gordon around it let's check out
the meatballs all right yeah all right
we're fine but now it's like we gotta
get a hazmat suit and all this [ __ ]
sucks not gonna be good for the movies
you know what I mean no true no [ __ ]
sad travesty really it's do you think
somehow
would this fix drugs in a way if
everyone who takes fentanyl dies
you are a dark man could that not be a
good thing some crazy ironic way yeah
like all drug users are dead but
wouldn't there still be curiosity which
would bring in new sets of people for
you you're like everyone could die right
Ryan's like here's a crazy idea if
everybody in the world is just dead
would anybody use drugs because I
remember in um in in uh you know back in
the Roaring 90s yeah I had asked this
question as a [ __ ] idiot and I
shouldn't have said this because it's
insensitive as [ __ ] but talking about
the AIDS crisis there's more people
hypothesized that if everyone who
currently had AIDS all died from it
right now wouldn't AIDS die too
I think that's what the government was
hoping
so is the government also hoping that
drug users die by letting fentanyl Run
free
in a way
I don't know I'm not gonna make any
assumptions but for some reason after
like Decades of this stuff I would
assume that the government's just like
oh it's the next drug yeah you know what
I mean people are going to die people
we're gonna get caught we're gonna like
Leverage [ __ ] whatever at least you
didn't make any assumptions about AIDS
first thank you and and when you say
when you say something like you know
this is the strongest one I mean like
wasn't every drug the first time that
they were handling it you know what I
mean almost yeah yeah so it's kind of
like I I would assume that this is just
the next drug you know it's the next
Crisis it's the next whatever makes
sense in that moment so when they're
saying like oh this is more potent than
the last is that just proportionately
not to be taken as seriously as what
they're it's the it's the most it's the
strongest in what has been released so
fentanyl I think in medical usage is
part of the epidural for girls when
they're gonna give birth so that's how
strong it is it's so strong where like
they put a little bit in bam in your
spine I don't [ __ ] feel [ __ ] [ __ ]
something that's this wide can come out
of my [ __ ] [ __ ] and then I don't
even I don't even scream oh my [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's how [ __ ] strong fentanyl
is they sound like doctors over there
yeah that started really good that's the
medical use of it so now imagine like
you know how like morphine is just
medical like opium or a heroin it's like
that yeah
and I would also I would also assume
that this impacts you know what I mean
the people or the users that are like
pushing the edge on that stuff right
like um let's take like ecstasy or the
idea of it for example when it was just
MDMA for therapeutic sense back in the
day the reason why it originated stuff
like that I'm sure it wasn't laced with
[ __ ] speed and heroin and all this
stuff right when people started using it
recreationally at parties and doing it
for the sake of trying to like turn up
but stay up and start lacing it with
other things that's when it became a
different thing once Euros hit the scene
and with these like four you know triple
stacked quadruple stacked press pills
that had all this other [ __ ] that would
keep it even going that's when like that
answered the scene people were just
pushing the bar and if they're pushing
the limit if you're a user you're you're
upping your ability to take it right I'm
guessing like with Bart like when you
first took X like how many pills did you
take versus when you were at your Peak
yeah one and then later on it was
probably eight a night Jesus you know
what I'm saying so when you're up in
your tolerance something like fentanyl
that's when it comes into play because
then you might I'd be like oh I'll just
take that one exit again but it's got a
little Fenton on it and this just bangs
you don't need to take a pills practical
use for it I would assume you're looking
for something strong baby come out of my
dick cold I won't even scream and is
that even the limit hey Mark is it is
that the limit can you push harder can
you push it hard can you push it up yeah
maybe yeah maybe [ __ ] blow my dick in
half see you think so maybe
is there a guy on the internet phone
who's like
[Laughter]
how about that maybe but but again back
to what I was saying I would assume
that's kind of the the particulars about
it right a new user who's suddenly and
accidentally finds himself in a
situation that's using something that
has been all you might [ __ ] get
blasted in straight diet but like it's
always let's say you're going to you
know you party hard and then there's
that one guy who comes to the party that
everybody knows apple is a [ __ ]
gangster with [ __ ] he's like you all got
the new [ __ ] that's blah blah it's like
that crowd for it with your system that
crowd runs with that [ __ ] because
they're always trying to find like the
crazy [ __ ] because the regular [ __ ] the
regular people kind of do doesn't even
[ __ ] phase him anymore the tolerance
difference yeah you think that drug
entrepreneurs are just trying to solve a
problem because it may be the the
customers are like oh my God everything
[ __ ] stronger manila's [ __ ] it's
not a week and then so they're just like
oh my customers want more yeah so I'll
put a little bit more of this guy in
there I'm getting three and a half stars
on Amazon how do I get this up to five I
doubt that problem is rooted in my
customers want more um I'm guessing it's
more like hey maybe there's more demand
but how can I more efficiently profit
and maximize my Supply right that's why
people always cut up [ __ ] and put stuff
in it you don't want your customers to
die either there goes all your clientele
that's true I feel like like fentanyl is
now the all-time leader for deaths among
like because all the old [ __ ] I don't
think people were like just [ __ ]
dying you know people like they have a
problem and that their life spirals out
of control with Coke like it was like
you had the odm cook which is like
thousands and thousands exactly but see
people's life deteriorate yeah if
there's someone you see someone lose
like 50 pounds in front of you yeah this
is just like bam they're just [ __ ]
and it's the rate of deaths that have
been happening since fentanyl has been
more popular I think it's like the
all-time leader right now so one of the
reasons I used to always think which I
don't believe this now but like I used
to think that the reason whenever a new
drug hit the scene and everyone was
talking about oh this is the new potent
thing everybody's dying everyone
I used to think that was partially if
not majority politics to get more
funding to destroy that market because
of the money the government's missing
out on and I didn't always believe that
this is the new killer but for the
fentanyl it almost sounds like it's it's
it's like half and half it's like it is
as true as it sounds and they also want
to stamp it out because it's a lot of
money's going that direction right
there's motivation on all sides it feels
like yeah I don't know what have you
heard from Cops though
about Fentanyl just that it's really
really strong in whatever [ __ ] that
people even thought was strong before
it's not even like a linear increase
it's just the exponential it's like
people usually go okay yeah like your
weed's not really addictive when you get
into meth it's kind of addictive and
like Coke oh [ __ ] heroin is kind of
scary it's like this and then it's not
like a logical of fentanyl it's here
it's more like fentanyl's here got it
yeah it's like
teeny tiny amounts that will [ __ ]
like blow your head off I knew fentanyl
is crazy when like my like Party friend
like did anybody else get like text uh
when uh I guess fentanyl just started
really hitting the scene and it was in
like cocaine and stuff like that so
people just didn't know where it was
going to be people started dying left
and right cocaine [ __ ] we're dying I
just got some like text from like you
know like the party friends and stuff
that were getting texts from other party
friends about bomb they're just like be
careful when you're like doing blow or
something like that because fentanyl's
you know I'd be like the [ __ ] like I
don't even talk to you in like years you
know what I mean but it was just like a
mass text I was being kind of sent out
in that kind of underground party type
of like circuit because people were just
dying and people cared enough to try and
spread the message hey watch out when
you do cocaine because there might be
Fenton on and you won't know how do
people know how do people know how do
you know why for it it's either you try
it or you don't right
do you know I don't even is there a
testing kit you can get nobody does that
though right you don't [ __ ] go to the
bathroom with your friend who hands you
a bag and goes let me [ __ ] test this
while we're in the bathroom with the
club my pool boy does a better job you
think drug users are responsible enough
to carry a test kit no of course not no
that was more of a rhetorical question I
didn't know that was actually going to
be a thing so my apologies
they were able to trace that this exact
shipment came from the Sinaloa cartel
and the Jalisco New Generation Jesus
that was a theory too right that like
all these competing drug cartels were
like poison the supply yeah and those
are those are two big daddy cartoons you
don't want and I would understand from
their perspective why they might want to
use it if it had like a truly highly
addictive property that wasn't killing
people what was just getting them
[ __ ] hooked in a in a way that
they're like you have done cocaine
before but this one hits you know it's
taking the limit takes me to the Limit
it pushes me to my lap
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]